Merhaba
[Müzik]
sevgili gençler Merhaba
Fikret kireci Ben Güneydoğu Anadolu
ihracatçılar Birliği Koordinatör
başkanıyım
burada Öncelikle
ek geç kardeşim de söyledi on bir tane
şehidimizi ve ondan öncekileri
saygıyla hürmetle B rahmetle anıyorum
bu vatan için yapılan hiçbir şey boşa
gitmez bundan kimsenin şüphesi olmasın
Ve tabii ki hedex
Bey Mahallesi Ökkeş beyin şahsında tüm
ekibi onları da çok teşekkür ediyorum
böyle bir organizasyona ev sahipliği
yapmayı bize verdikleri için
şimdi bu konuşma ile ilgili bugünkü
programla ilgili bi geçen seneden Ökkeş
böyle bir arkadaşlarla konuşmuştuk
aslında hesabımızda şu vardı bu Salonu
tıklım tıklım doldurup Bütün Türkiye'ye
gençlerin neler yapabileceğini
anlatmaktı ama maalesef şartlar bizi çok
başka bir noktaya getirdi Abi şu anda
pandemi şartlarında
da olabildiğince
aktarmak adına öyle YouTube'dan Zoom dan
yani dijital dünyanın tüm nimetlerinden
faydalanarak
sizlere birtakım mesajlar vermeye
çalışacağız Biz kıymetli gençler Ben
hiçbirinize şunu söyleyeceğim sakın
böyle bir şey benden beklemeyin ama çok
çalışın annenizin babanızın dediğinden
çıkmayın asla böyle şeyler
söylemeyeceğim Siz birey olarak şahıs
olarak
kendi doğrularımızı yapın ama bu
doğruları yakalarken de
geçmişteki yaşanan tecrübelerden mutlaka
faydalanın Çünkü onların hepsi birer
birer
bedeller ödenerek
yaşanan edinilen kazanılmış lık vardır
bir hiçbir
kazanın boşa çıkmayacaktır arkadaşlar
Dolayısıyla o eskiye de
bilgi YDS da almamız gerekiyor
bir defa benim konuşmamın da başlangıcı
iki teker üzerinde
takım elbise Yani şunu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum arkadaşlar
hem kariyer hem de hobilerinizi
yapabilirsiniz sadece bir konuya
odaklanma yayın mutlaka kendinize zaman
ayırın
spordan hoşlanıyorsanız spor yapın
dağcılıkta hoşlanıyorsanız dağcılık
yapın ama Mesleğinizi de yapın ve
Mesleğinizi seçerken mutlaka
kendinize uygun bir meslek Seçil mümkün
olduğu kadar tabii ki Bu mümkün değilse
profesyonellik İlke çerçevesinde
yine bunun Altından kalkabilir siniz
hayatınızı kendi sağlığınızı ve iş
hayatınızı mutlaka birbirinden ayırmamız
lazım ev aile ilişkilerinizi arkadaşlık
larınızı iş hayatımızı ve bu
karıştırmamız lazım
Burada Eğer bunun tersini yaparsanız
Evet Hayat öyle de geçer böyle de ama
kesinlikle be çok mutlu olamazsınız
başarılı olabilirsiniz ama çok başarılı
olamazsınız mutlu olabilirsiniz ama çok
mutlu olamazsınız Çünkü insan mutlu
olması için gerçekten başarılı olması
için kendi idealleri ve kendi doğruları
doğrultusunda hareket etmesi lazım
şimdi bu çok farklı fikirler olabilir
çok farklı özgürlükler olabilir dünyanın
güzelliği çok farklı fikirlerin bir
arada ortak bir araya gelip
birtakım işleri birlikte baş armasıyla
mümkün olacaktır öbür türlü Herkes kendi
fikrinin yoluna giderse hiçbir başarı
çıkmaz ortaya ne zaman ki benim
özgürlüklerim benim
sınırlarım sizin sınırlarınız a
dayandığı an orada durmasını bilmemiz
lazım Eğer o sınırı bilemiyorsun o
sırada ötesine geçiyorsa kesinlikle işte
orada karşıya ve kendimize saygısızlık
etmiş oluruz herkesin mutlaka bir fikri
olacak herkesin mutlaka bir ideal olacak
bir yaşam şekli bir felsefesi olacak ama
nereye kadar karşısındakinin sınırına
kadar ben karşımdaki insanı fikirlerinde
etkilemek zorunda değilim böyle bir şey
yok yok Onun fikirleri farklıdır Benim
fikirlerim farklıdır ama amacımız
aynıdır amaç nedir insanlığı belli bir
noktaya taşımak insanlığı huzur ve barış
içerisinde yaşatmak
bu yöntemler
farklıdır ama Hedef aynıdır hayatınızı
Bu felsefe üzerine kurmamız lazım
şimdi burada benden sonraki arkadaşlarım
da çok öyle güzel bilgiler verecekler
size genç kardeşlerim Lütfen bir hobiniz
olsun mutlaka kendinize zaman ayırın
mutlaka sevdiğiniz işleri yapmaya
çalışın
bu Eğer bunda şartlarınız el vermiyorsa
az önce söylediğim gibi profesyonellik
çerçevesinde o sınırlar içerisinde dene
Siz kimsenin sınırına müdahale edin ve
de kimsenin sizin sınırımıza müdahale
etmesine izin vermeyin Çünkü siz hepiniz
birer bireyiz bu dünyada en kolay olan
ama şartlar gereği en zor olan şey birey
olmak
bunu hiç kimseye kaptırmayın kendi
özgürlüklerimizi kendi ideallerinizi
kendi fikirlerinize de sahip çıkın
bunları doğru dille etrafımızı anlatın
herkese bunu kabul ettirmek zorunda
değilsin Ölüm mecburiyetimiz yok
kesinlikle yok
bu Ama kabul edenlerle birlikte bu yolda
yürüyebilirsiniz şimdi ben burada takım
elbiseli çok ciddi bir kurumun yurt
temsilcisi olarak sizin karşınızdayım
Ama bu takım elbisenin arkasında çok
farklı bir insan da var Kızın durduğu
Kardeşim burada çalışma arkadaşlarım
burada birçok kendi tanıdığım Hocam
arkadaşlar herkes burada Beni iyi kötü
biliyorlar bunu Birazcıkta ben iki kere
böyle birkaç kelimeyle anlatayım size
Evet ben bir tarafta profesyonelce bu
bulunduğum koruma oturduğum koltuğa
lâyıkıyla hizmet etmeye çalışıyorum ama
onun arkasında da bir başka bir Fikret
var
çocukluğundan beri hep özgürlüğüne
düşkün oto siklet kullanmış top oynamış
kayak yapmış sürekli ben şöyle
söyleyeyim Arkadaşlar bu motosiklet Bir
de bundan öncesi vardı o bu eşimle
birlikte tüm Avrupa'yı gezdik biz
Evet şimdi normal şartlarda çok garip
geliyor ya motorla Avrupa gezilirmi
geçirir çok da güzel gezilir
o Üstelik de çok keyif alırsınız ama
nedir kurallar ve Kaideler çerçevesinde
Bakın ben normalde buraya gelirken kask
takmaya bilirdim bu kaskı takarak size
bir şey anlatmaya çalışıyorum Her işin
bir kuralı vardır bir Kaidesi vardır o
kural ve kaideleri çerçevesinde hareket
ettiğiniz zaman problem çıkmaz
tedbirinizi alacaksınız sonra Siz kendi
işinize bakacaksınız sizin dışınızda
gelişen olaylar
öncesinde Siz kendi emniyetiniz bir
şekilde almamız gerekiyor Dolayısıyla
benim size tavsiyem Kural ve kaidelere
lütfen riayet edin ve onlara uyarak
uymayanları da uyararak yaşantımıza
devam edelim Bu pembe mi ile ilgili çok
büyük problemler yaşıyoruz arkadaşlar
dünya bütün ezberleri bozdu bildiğimiz
bütün doğrular yanlış yanlış Ne oldu
şimdi belli sektörlerde belli kuralları
bir şekilde gevşetmek zorundayız Çünkü
insanların artık bir noktada Dayanacak
gücüm de kalmadı ama bunu yaparken
lütfen kuralları ve kaidelere uyuyalım
bakın Biz Gaziantep'te Şimdi burada
sadece Gaziantep'te bütün Türkiye bizi
izliyor
rengi Sarık mavi turuncu kırmızı hiç
fark etmiyor Bu kurallar uyulmadığı
sürece bu pandemi Bu hastalık bu illet
inanın bize çok büyük bedeller ötecek
Biz şu ana kadar dünyada en az bedel
ödeyen ülkelerden bir tanesiyiz buradan
sonraki süreç İnanın bana bundan önceki
süreçten çok çok daha önemli çok çok
daha dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor maskemiz
livesafe mizi ve hijyen imizi
temizliğimiz iri uygulamak ve yerine bir
tek zorundayız maske takma yakınları
kesinlikle uyarmak zorundayız Biz mümkün
olduğu kadar topluluklardan kalabalık
ortamlardan uzak durmak zorundayız Şimdi
burada ddx ben bunları söylüyorum Çünkü
birazcık da kurumundan ve
bir şekilde temsil ettiği makamdan
dolayı bunu insanları anlatmamız
gerekiyor
etrafımızdaki herkese bütün insanlara
bunu bir şekilde anlatmamız gerekiyor
kendimizi korumamız gerekiyor
Evet arkadaşlar
biz ihracatçılar Birliği olarak
ihracatçılar olarak tüm gençlere çok
önem veriyoruz bizim çok ciddi
eğitimlerimiz var bizim çok ciddi
webinarları mız var web sayfamızdan
sosyal medyadan takip ederek bunlara
ulaşabilirsiniz Sizden ricam lütfen ama
lütfen Bizimkini ya da başkasını
eğitimle ilgili olan her şeyi takip edin
eğitimle ilgili olan kişisel gelişimle
ilgili olan her şeye önem verin ama
sakın kendi Özel hayatınızı boşa
geçirmeyin mutlaka bir hobiniz olsun
mutlaka ama mutlaka Birileri size bunu
engellemek isterse bunun karşısında
durun ve bunu yapmaya Bununla birlikte
yaşamaya da Özen gösterin Çünkü öbür
türlü ya hakkaten bunu bir kaç defa
söyledim Ne olursunuz ben işim de çok
gaddar bir adamımdır kurallarım Vardır
kaidelerin vardır ama işin dışında da
böyle özgür bir adamımdır Ben kayak
yaparım Ben tenis oynarım
bunları yaparken değil insanlara
saygısızlık ederek değil saygı
çerçevesinde kurallar çerçevesinde
yapmaya çalışırım Siz de aynı şey yapın
mutlaka ve mutlaka bir hobiniz Zin
peşinden gidin ideallerinin peşinden
gidin hayalkurun hayallerimiz olsun ama
sakın Hayalperest olmayın
kurduğunuz Hayaller yere bassın yani
yapabileceğiniz hayalleri kurun
idealleriniz olsun idealist oğlu ama
ithal ellerinizin çok böyle esiri
olmayın günümüz şartlarında birtakım
şeyleri gerçekleştirmeye bilirsiniz
onları ve biz edin Bugün dünya değişiyor
bugün bütün şartlar değişiyor Ben dün
doğru bildiklerimiz bugün yanlış oluyor
Dün asla yapmayız dediklerimizi bugün
yapar hale geliyoruz bakın Bütün dünya
ekran içersine sığdığı bir şekilde bir
ekran içerisinde bütün dünyayı
yaşayabiliyoruz hiçbir yere gitmeden
kıllarımızı kıpırdatmadan adım atmadan
bütün dünyaya kendimizi tanıtan
biliyoruz bundan daha büyük bir şey
olamaz dijital dünyayı sonuna kadar
kullanın dijitalleşme yi asla ve asla
defans yapmayın buna karşı açık olun
yeniliğe açık olun etrafınızdakileri
Eğer size uymuyorsa bir şekilde uygun
bir lisanla uyarın ama onlara yani Mete
Zorlu değil odam kabul etmeyebilir sizin
işiniz onunla olmasın insanları
değiştirmekle çok uğraşmayın Ben Bu
yaşımda bunu öğrendim birilerini çok
böyle değiştirmeye çalışmak hakkaten
insan O yüzden alıyor Ama ben doğru
bildiğimi anlatıyorum doğru bir tanedir
ya siz beni
ikna edeceksiniz Ya ben sizi ikna
edeceğim Ama bir Ortak noktada
buluşacağız Ben karşımdaki insana kendi
doğrularımı
anlatmaya çalışıyorum ama o yanlışında
devam ediyorsa orayı bırakacaksınız
Çünkü o da zaman kaybetmeyin bir
başkasına geçin sonra bir başkasına
geçin ki bu çerçeve büyütsün
bu Çünkü arkadaşlar
gelecek hakikaten hakikaten geçmişten
çok daha zor belli kurallara uymazsak
geçmişte yaşam çok daha kolaydı Ben
Çocukluğum hatırlıyorum Biz üç kardeş
bir odada büyüdük Annen baban öğretmen
şimdi bakıyorum Her çocuğun bir odası
var
Bizim en büyük oyuncağımız bizim işte
top açımız vardı Ne bileyim bir
yerlerimiz vardı çok farklı
oyuncaklarımız vardı
ama şimdi bakın mesela bunu bizim
eğitimci arkadaşlardan aldım Size
satıyorum açık ve net Siz meydanlar
üstüne olduğunu bilmezsiniz
anabiritanika ayı bilmezsiniz ama biz
çok iyi biliriz Çünkü biz onlarla büyüdü
katan onlarla büyüdük yok Atlas larla
büyüdük Ama siz şimdi akıllı
telefonunuza yazıyorsunuz istediğiniz
şeyi Tıp bütün bilgiler önünüze
dökülüyor Biz de öyle değildi Biz o
bilgiye ulaşmak için çok böyle çaba sarf
etmemiz lazımdı bizim il halk
kütüphanemiz vardı biz oraya giderdik
Mesela bir bilgi araştırmak için siz
şimdi oturduğunuz yerde çayınızı
kahvenizi içtiniz yerde tık tık tık
hemen buluyorsunuz İşte bundan
faydalanmak lazım bundan doğru yönelmek
lazım Ha birşeyde tırnak içerisinde
Kesinlikle söylemem gerekiyor internette
gördüğünüz her şeyi de sakın ha sakın
doğru kabul etmeyin burada da bir bilgi
kirliliği var burada da çok
manipülasyonlar var çok farklı farklı
yönlendiren yönlendirmeler var Siz
hepiniz akıllı insanlarsınız aklınızın
ve mantığınız ın doğru gördüğü şeyleri
yapın her yazılana her söyle bu
inanmayın analiz yeteneğimiz var bizim
bir o analiz yeteneğini mukayese
yeteneğini kullanın ve doğru olanın
peşinden gidin kesinlikle ama kesinlikle
körü körüne bir işin peşine gitmeyin
şimdi çok az bir zaman kaldı nasıl
tamamlamam lazım dönüp dolaşıp aynı
şeyleri söylüyorum Ne olur siz olun bir
başkasının dediği değil siz olun Siz
kendinizi nasıl görmek istiyorsanız
Kendinizi bu dünyanın neresinde
konuşulan duruyor sanız Hangi konumda
olmayı görüyorsanız onu olup birilerinin
söylediğine değil ama bunu yaparken de
başta söylediğimi bir daha söylüyorum
Lütfen ama lütfen
geçmişin tecrübelerine ve bilgilerine
Saygı duyun onları analiz edin
bu doğru olanlarını cebinize koyun ama
Yanlış olanları atın bir kenara Ve son
olarak da bu bayrağın ve bu
bu atamızın izinden
Ben asla ve asla
vazgeçmeyin sürekli bu iki olgunun
arasında olun ve şahsiyetin izden
kişiliğiniz den onurunuz dan hiçbir şey
kaybetmeyin değerleriniz olsun ve
değerlerinizin de öncüsü
Bunlar olsun hepinize teşekkür ediyorum
saygılar sunuyorum Bir sonrakinde daha
sonrakilerde tekrar görüşmek üzere
diyorum Hepinize
bol neşeli sağlıklı mutlu günler
diliyorum Çok sağ olun
[Alkış]